[Musique]
une fuite massive qui a des échos dans
le monde entier plus de dix mille pages
de documents provenant des entrailles du
géant facebook des secrets bien gardés
désormais entre les mains d'élus
américains et d'un consortium d'une
vingtaine de médias
pour l'essentiel il s'agit de
communication interne et d' analyses
menées par des employés tout part de
cette femme et de son témoignage à
visière levée francis arguin ancien
ingénieur dans le département
d'intégrité civique de facebook et
depuis une semaine les vannes sont
ouvertes des journalistes lèvent le
voile sur le contenu de cette fuite et
ce n'est que le début
bon avant toute chose jeff et nicolas je
pense qu'on va devoir placer un peu le
contexte dans lequel cette fuite massive
a eu lieu d'où son origine les facebook
peppers cette fête est une continuation
en quelque sorte de facebook france dont
parlait le voir suggérons il ya
plusieurs semaines ya plusieurs de
documents qui sont les mêmes donc on
apprenait à l'époque leur bon que
facebook était au courant plusieurs
problèmes sur cette plateforme on pense
notamment à l'effet d'instagram sur la
santé mentale des jeunes filles au rôle
que joue et facebook à l'assaut du
capitole le 6 janvier mais maintenant on
apprend encore plus de choses avec les
facebook et plus donc beaucoup de choses
qu'on savait déjà au préalable mais lens
est intéressant de savoir jusqu'à quel
point il ya des employés al internes qui
ont tiré la sonnette d'alarmé qui ont
fait des propositions et se sont butés
un mur
c'est un des grands constats qu'on voit
dans tous les articles ont été écrits
sur les fesses b'hook papers les
employés de facebook sont au courant des
problèmes de la plateforme même des
études c'est de proposer des solutions
pi la gestion de facebook répond pas
toujours alors suggestions d'ailleurs un
article de wired sur ce qu'on appelle
les badges pose donc une tradition chez
facebook ou quand un employé quitte
humaine photo de sa carte d'accès pis
bon décrit son expérience chez facebook
pour la porte du temps cédé sous les
messages qui sont positifs ont dit avoir
aimé travailler chez facebook
mais on le voit dans les fesses b'hook
papers plusieurs messages quand même
négatif de même un employé alors parti
qui écrit je ne suis même pas certain
que facebook qu'il devrait exister donc
on sent que quand même frustration en
interne chez facebook et moi ce qui m'a
frappé dans ces facebook peppers c'est
la question de la modération qui très
problématique dans la mesure où facebook
et est présente dans plus de 190 pays
avec 3 milliard d'utilisateurs mensuels
qui s'exprime en plus de 160 langues
différentes il est là le problème ben
exactement parce qu'on a vu déjà les
conséquences concrètes que pour avoir
facebook sur une société où on mentionne
encore l'assaut du capitole le 6 janvier
aux etats unis mais ce qui est
intéressant dans tout ça c'est que les
états unis représentent seulement 10%
des utilisateurs facebook mais on 87%
des ressources de la plate forme qui lui
sont dédiés pour la lutte à la
désinformation donc ça laisse seulement
13 % de ces ressources là pour tout le
reste du monde et ces outils là sont
encore meilleures en anglais que dans
d'autres langues alors que deux tiers
des utilisateurs facebook ne parle pas
l'anglais ses conséquences qui sont très
visibles dans une langue comme l'arabe
qui est la troisième langue la plus
parlée sur facebook plus de 220 millions
d'utilisateurs tu parle l'arabe sur la
plateforme mais comme l'expliqué
document dé facebook peppers comme le
rapporte le monde de la rade c'est juste
une langue c'est plus comme une famille
de langues et toutes sortes de dialectes
différents arabes qui sont parlées et la
modération en arabe se fait au maroc et
en partie aussi en mais ça fait en sorte
que selon ce que 10 des employés dans
ces documents là ben il ya des algériens
des tunisiens et des libyens qui sont
carrément laisser le temps au loin par
cette modération là il ya toutes sortes
de propos haineux ou d'incitation à la
violence qui ne sont pas vus par le fils
de facebook et c'est seulement 2% des
contenus un nul on apprend que sont
détectés par l'intelligence artificielle
en afghanistan et encore une fois ce
facebook on est au courant et ne pose
pas beaucoup de gestes pour aller alliés
a sûrement heureux finalement il ya un
exemple qui est très frappant très
patent c'est celui de l'inde un immense
pays avec vingt deux langues officielles
avec 22 langues officielles mais
seulement 5 d'entre elles sont reconnues
par l'intelligence artificielle de
facebook et on rapporte une expérience
d'une android facebook qui s'est ouvert
un compte en est avec une mission très
simple suivent les recommandations de
facebook pendant trois semaines et voir
vers où cela a mené elle décrit une
marée de désinformation d'incitation à
la haine d'excitation à la violence sur
son fil d'actualité facebook en trois
semaines l' empire de facebook est
indissociable de son président et
fondateur mark zuckerberg sur qui on a
appris pas mal de choses danseurs sur
son mode de gestion
mais on voit que les pouvoirs de
décision chez facebook sont centralisées
son collègue mexicain qui est
l'actionnaire principal de facebook
estime prendre la plupart des décisions
il ya même des employés qui semble être
qui devra
entre les décisions sur le contenu comme
édition de retirer certains certains
comptes certains groupes certaines
publications et hexa coeurs on dit que
on s'immisce beaucoup dans l'est dans
les décisions de l'équipe d'intégrité ou
de sécurité lorsqu'il est question de
politique donc on essaie de faire de
faire plaisir à des politiciens on
essaye de ne pas trop à les attirer des
cons pour pas trop les fâchés donc on
voit vraiment qu'il ya un malaise avec
avec centralisation du pouvoir chez
facebook et sa des échos à
l'international messieurs que bouygues
qui était revenue qui est intervenu
directement dans certes certains
dossiers dans certains pays très
instable
mais on peut penser notamment au vietnam
le gouvernement vietnamien qui a demandé
à facebook essentiellement de censurer
des propos anti gouvernement ou bien de
fermer sa plateforme au pays au grand
complet la décision est revenu à
monsieur claude lui-même qui a décidé de
plier de laisser le gouvernement
censurer tout ce qu'elle a à l'encontre
de son discours officiel sur facebook
donne un exemple de comment il ya une
mainmise sur les décisions facebook et
on parle aussi les décisions de micro
gestion le carrément de choisir les
couleurs de filtres pour dire qu'on
était vaccinée qu'on a que 28 9% quelque
chose de côté les grandes conséquences
non mais c'est une idée à quel point de
voir les petites décisions même type
facebook et que penser de la réponse de
facebook à ses facebook peuvent ils
encore et pas mal de choses à vous
monsieur joe kubert qui dit que la
critique de bonne foi saeed facebook à
s'améliorer mais que selon lui il s'agit
pas ici d'une critique de bonne foi mais
vraiment d'une attaque concertée le des
médias qui qui ne présente pas tous les
faits qui sont la peau distordre la
réalité selon ce qui dit il estime que
facebook fait beaucoup d'efforts de
modération mais on ne marque pas moins
que de constater
c'est que c'est peut-être pas assez
selon beaucoup des employés en interne
c'est quand même étrange comme posture
de dire que si la négativité des médias
qui attaquent facebook alors que les
documents sont dits pour la plupart des
communications internes d'employés de
facebook qui émettent ces critiques
l'avoir employé donc c'est un peu un
argument qui ne tient pas vraiment la
route parce que c'est vraiment ce sont
des documents c'est pour des opinions
mais peu importe ce que rétorque
facebook une chose est certaine cette
fuite je n'ai pas terminé les documents
continue à être acheminée aux
journalistes et qu'ils vont poursuivre
leur travail de disséminer est-ce qu'ils
euros
nichée d'intéressant et d'intérêt public
dans tout ça voilà ce qu'on peut en
conclure trois petits points de
suspension